happiness is an emotional response to an
outcome if I win I will be happy if I
don't I won't it's an if then cause and
effect quid proquo standard that we
cannot sustain because we immediately
raise it every time we attain it you see
happiness happiness Demands a certain
outcome it is result Reliant and I say
if happiness is what you're after you're
going to be let down frequently and
you're going to be unhappy much of your
time Joy though Joy is a different thing
it's something else Joy is not a choice
it's not a response to some result it's
a constant Joy is the feeling that we
have from doing what we are fashioned to
do no matter the outcome